[Music]
cardi B was living her best life at the
Super Bowl in part because of this
moment
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been you the secure is gonna
perform I like it for me to even know
that she was gonna perform I like it I
just be like your that is crazy like do
they even understand they're like I grew
up listening to these people like this
sometimes I I just cannot believed it
like this is crazy
cardi getting choked up is getting me a
little choked up come on
okay back to cardies insta live she
apparently grew up a big fan of secure
us there was a point that Shakira was
just so popular she was just putting up
music music music music out music out
first like like I remember like the
first song dish that we heard from her
there I was a little girl when crazy was
the Sun they should be like Boop that
singer so I knew that she was like a
punk rock is she was kind of like a punk
rakesh pop Spanish artist and then she
came with the belly dancing era and
everybody liking Washington Heights in
the bronze they wanted to be like Benny
dancers and everything if you listen
closely you can hear cardi singing along
to Shaq set on her story
[Applause]
as if we couldn't love cardi more people
of course cardies got ties to Shakira's
co-headliner jennifer lopez - they've
worked together a few times first of all
for me to even know JLo for me to even
have conversations with JLo from you
even through a song with JLo I just some
size can I even like believe it a
digested but she's also a big fans
[Music]
I really grew up listening to these
people and just seeing them in person
performing that is it's beyond like a
blessing it's just like wow
life is crazy like I would never think
that this would be my destiny and in
life and I'm so thankful and I'm so
grateful cardi B for halftime show in
2021
oh snap and snap snap until then here
are some more highlights from cardis
night in Miami again she was loving it
[Music]
you'll get the celebrated can fight with
me
okay just gonna sit here and watch that
story on a loop until it expires until
next time ET will be here to bring you
all the latest on cardi I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]